JONATHAN, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR MORE ON THE LATEST, LET’S GO
TO TO THE BORDER IN DEL RIO, THE
NATIONAL BORDER PATROL COUNCIL
PRESIDENT BRANDON JUDD JOINS ME
WHERE THE GOVERNORS OF FLORIDA
AND TEXAS WILL BE THERE.
OF BRANDON, THANKS FOR TAKING
TIME FOR JOINING US.
LET ME BUILD UPON JONATHAN
SERRIE’S LAST PART OF HIS REPORT
THERE TALKING ABOUT THE POSSIBLE
LIFTING OF TITLE 42.
WHEN I LOOKED AT THESE NUMBERS,
I LOOKED IN THE RGV SECTOR,
PARTICULARLY THE HARDEST HIT
AREA AT THE OTHER THAN MEXICAN,
NON-UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN.
THAT’S A LITTLE TECHNICAL THERE,
BUT THAT’S BASICALLY SINGLE
ADULTS THAT AREN’T FROM MEXICO,
THOSE FROM THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE, UP MORE THAN 756%.
DOES THAT TREND WORRY YOU WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE POSSIBILITY OF
LIFTING TITLE 42?
>> IT’S ONE OF THE BIGGEST
WORRIES THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT GETTING RID
OF TITLE 42 AND YOU’RE TALKING
ABOUT AN UNPRECEDENTED CRISIS
WE’VE NEVER SEEN BEFORE AND
WE’RE DEALING WITH SO MANY
PEOPLE FROM AROUND THE WORLD NOT
JUST MEXICO, NOT JUST THE
NORTHERN TRIANGLE, BUT FROM
AROUND THE WORLD, AND WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT GETTING RID OF TITLE
42, ALL YOU’RE DOING IS INVITING
MORE AND MORE PEOPLE TO COME IN.
THE NUMBERS CONTINUE TO GO UP
MONTH AFTER MONTH WHICH CLEARLY
SHOWS THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT CARE
ABOUT BORDER SKIRT AND,
THEREFORE, DOES -- SECURITY AND,
THEREFORE, DOES NOT CARE ABOUT
THE SAFETY AND SECURITY OF THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC.
GRIFF: WHEN WE TALK ABOUT WHY
PEOPLE CROSS OUR BORDER
ILLEGALLY, WE LOOK AT THE PUSH
FACTORS AND THE PULL FACTORS
WHICH IS INCENTIVES LIKE THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT AN
ADMINISTRATION COULD BE FRIENDLY
TO THEM.
WHEN YOU SAY THE ADMINISTRATION
DOESN’T CARE, ARE YOU
SPECIFICALLY POINTING TO THE
FACT THAT THEY’RE NOT ADDRESSING
THAT PULL FACTOR OF THE FACT
THAT SO MANY ARE COMING?
>> THE PUSH FACTORS HAVE ALWAYS
EXISTED IN THESE COUNTRIES.
THE PULL FACTOR IS WHAT HAS BEEN
MISSING, AND THAT’S WHAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS DONE.
THEY’VE BROUGHT BACK CATCH AND
RELEASE.
THAT IS THE MAG INNOCENT THAT’S
DRAWN SO MANY -- MAGNET THAT’S
DRAWN SO MANY PEOPLE HERE
ILLEGALLY.
OF COURSE IT’S INCENTIVIZING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
AND WHEN YOU REWARD PEOPLE FOR
VIOLATING THE LAW, YOU CAN
EXPECT MORE PEOPLE TO DO EXACTLY
THAT.
GRIFF: WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE JUNE
NUMBERS, 188,829, IN MAY 180,000
PLUS, YOU ARE SEEING NUMBERS
THAT WE HAVE NOT SEEN IN MORE
THAN 20 YEARS.
WALK IT OUT FOR ME, BRANDON.
WHAT HAPPENS IF THIS DOESN’T GET
UNDER CONTROL?
>> IN REALITY WE’VE NEVER SEEN
THESE NUMBERS BEFORE.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT FISCAL YEAR,
YOU’VE GOT TO REMEMBER THAT
THREE OF THOSE MONTHS WERE UNDER
PRESIDENT TRUMP, AND THOSE
MONTHS WERE LOW MONTHS.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT A CALENDAR
YEAR, WE ARE ON PACE TO SET
RECORD NUMBERS FOR A CALENDAR
YEAR.
WE’VE NEVER SEEN MONTH OVER
MONTH OVER MONTH RISES LIKE WHAT
WE’RE SEEING TODAY.
SO THIS IS THE BIGGEST CRISIS
WE’VE EVER FACED.
WE’VE NEVER FACED THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE FROM OTHER COUNTRIES
WE’RE SEEING RIGHT NOW.
THIS CLEARLY IS AN
ADMINISTRATION-DRIVEN ISSUE, AND
THE ADMINISTRATION JUST ISN’T
DOING ANYTHING TO FIX IT, AND WE
CAN EXPECT IT TO GET WORSE.
GRIFF: WHEN I WAS IN DEL RIO A
MONTH AGO N A WEEK OF TIME THERE
WAS APPREHENSIONS OF MORE THAN
35 COUNTRIES, FOR THE MONTH IT
WAS MORE THAN 70.
YOU HAVE GOVERNOR DeSANTIS
COMING FROM FLORIDA.
YOU WILL BE AT THE MEETING WITH
GOVERNOR ABBOTT AND GOVERNOR
DeSANTIS.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT THE TRIP,
AND WHAT WILL THE GOVERNOR SEE,
DeSANTIS, THAT IS, THAT’S SO
IMPORTANT?
>> THIS JUST SHOWS YOU HOW BAD
THIS PROBLEM IS.
THE NUMBER OF DRUGS THAT ARE
ENTERING OUR COUNTRY, KILLING
OUR CHILDREN, THE CDC JUST CAME
OUT AND SAID WE’VE NEVER HAD
MORE DRUG OVERDOSE DEATHS THAN
WHAT WE’RE SEEING RIGHT NOW.
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS IS WORRIED
ABOUT HIS STATE, HE’S WORRIED
ABOUT THE PROBLEMS THAT CROSS
OUR BORDER ILLEGALLY AND GO INTO
HIS STATE.
AND THERE’S SEVERAL OTHER
GOVERNORS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
BECAUSE THEY KNOW IT’S NOT JUST
AFFECTING TEXAS, ARIZONA,
CALIFORNIA, NEW MEXICO, IT’S
AFFECTING EVERY STATE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
AND IF WE DON’T GET THIS UNDER
CONTROL, IT’S GOING TO CONTINUE
TO GET WORSE.
THE PROBLEM IS THIS IS AN EASY
SOLUTION.
THIS ISN’T SOMETHING THAT TAKES
A LOT OF WORK TO GET UNDER
CONTROL.
THIS ADMINISTRATION JUST DOESN’T
HAVE THE POLITICAL WILL TO DO
IT.
GRIFF: BRANDON, FLORIDA IS A
HANDFUL, ONE OF A HANDFUL OF
STATEMENTS AND GOVERNORS WHO
HAVE PLEDGED SUPPORT, RESOURCES,
NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS TO
GOVERNOR ABBOTT IN TEXAS.
DO YOU BELIEVE AS SOMEONE WHO IS
ON THE OPERATIONAL SIDE OF THIS,
YOU KNOW, WILL THAT HELP?
WHAT CAN IT DO TO HELP TRY AND
PERHAPS GET THINGS UNDER
CONTROL?
>> IT WILL HELP US AS FAR AS THE
NUMBER OF GOTAWAYS.
SO NOT ONLY ARE WE ARRESTING
MORE PEOPLE THAN WE’VE WITH EVER
SEEN BEFORE, BUT WE’RE HAVING
MORE PEOPLE GET AWAY THAN WE’VE
EVER SEEN BEFORE AS WELL, AND
THAT’S GOING TO HELP.
THE PROBLEM IS THEY CAN’T DO
ANYTHING ABOUT THE CATCH AND
RELEASE.
THAT HAS TO BE AN
ADMINISTRATION-SOLVED ISSUE.
WE CAN PUT AS MANY PEOPLE ON THE
BORDER AS WE WANT, AND WE’RE
GOING TO ARREST A RECORD NUMBER
OF PEOPLE, BUT PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO COME, AND THAT’S
THE NUMBER ONE PROBLEM.
GRIFF: HAVE YOU BEEN INVITED TO
THE WHITE HOUSE?
HAVE YOU MET WITH EITHER VICE
PRESIDENT HARRIS OR PRESIDENT
BIDEN ABOUT THIS CRISIS?
>> I HAVE NOT, AND THAT’S WHAT’S
SO DISAPPOINTING ABOUT THIS.
THEY ONLY CARE ABOUT THEIR BASE.
THEY’RE ONLY LISTENING TO THEIR
BASE.
THEY’RE NOT GOING TO LISTEN TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING TO GIVE
THEM ACTUAL ADVICE.
AS SOMEBODY WHO’S ENDORSED
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS ALIKE,
THAT’S MYSELF, YOU WOULD THINK
THEY WOULD WANT A PERSPECTIVE
FROM BOOTS ON THE GROUND WHAT’S
ACTUALLY GOING ON, WHAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE.
BUT BECAUSE THEY DO NOT HAVE THE
WILL TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM,
THEY’RE NOT GOING TO INVITE
PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF TO GIVE THEM
THE ADVICE THAT THEY NEED IN
ORDER TO GET THIS UNDER CONTROL.
GRIFF: AND LASTLY, JUST ABOUT 30
SECONDS HERE, BRANDON, BUT I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT INCREASING
NUMBER OF CRIMINAL MIGRANTS THAT
ARE BEING APPREHENSIONED.
WE SEE ON TWITTER THE --
APPREHENDED.
HOW BIG OF A PROBLEM IS THAT?
>> THAT’S ANOTHER THING THAT
WE’VE NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
THIS IS, AGAIN, WE’RE BREAKING
RECORDS IN EVERY SINGLE
CATEGORY.
WE’RE SEEING MORE SEX CRIME
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN ARRESTED
FOR SEX CRIMES, WE’RE SEEING
MORE PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN
WANTED FOR MURDER.
WE’RE SEEING MORE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE COMMITTED VIOLENT CRIMES IN
THIS COUNTRY THAT ARE CROSSING
THE BORDER ILLEGALLY.
AGAIN, THIS IS A PROBLEM THAT
CAN BE SOLVED, THIS
ADMINISTRATION JUST DOESN’T HAVE
THE WILL.
AND, GRIFF, IF YOU DON’T MIND
IF, I WOULD LIKE TO WISH A VERY
HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO SOMEBODY VERY
SPECIAL IN MY LIFE, MY MOTHER.
SHE SUPPORTS 100% BORDER
SECURITY, AND I APPRECIATE YOU
ALLOWING ME TO DO THAT.
GRIFF: HAPPY BIRTHDAY, MAMA
JUDD.
I KNOW IT’S OVERWHELMING FOR THE
AGENTS THERE BECAUSE EVERYONE
I’VE TALKED TO IS OVERWHELMED IN
THE SITUATION.